[音楽]
皆さんはじめまして
僕は4月に名古屋大学を卒業し現在株式会社
カンパニーというスタートアップの代表しています高橋葉介と言います
今回のテックス名古屋指のテーマはイズムです
なので今日は僕がどんな考えを大切にしているのかについて少しお話しをさせてもらえ
ばと思います
僕は経営をする株式会社アカンパニーではメンバーにこうあるべしという
バリューというものが存在します
それは
ビークル b 発火です
ここで言ってくれるとは
自分を大切にし他人を思いやれる振る舞いをクールであるとしています
他人を蹴落とし自分の利益を追う姿勢や自分を犠牲にして他人のために報道することは
クールではない
人としてカッコいい彼そんな風に提供しています
貼った後はいい
自身の行動をコントロールし継続的な改善を繰り返し
自分の人生をコントロールできる人だっ
白水人のことである
担任技術力が高いという意味ではありません
積極的に世の中のくだらないもの問題を解決し自分の意思を持たず
か人の意見に流される人はハッカーではないと定義しています
つまり
自分のことを大切にしながらも人を思いやり
行動をより良い方向に進むためにコントロールできる人でありましょうということです
僕の理想のあり方でもあります
僕がこの相方には欠かせない14年オスロ
二つあると思っています
一つ目は
シンプルな思考です
シンプルな思考は特に決算を許す場面で重要です
僕が企業決断したとき
このシンプルな思考が僕の背中を後押ししてくれました
そもそもなぜ僕が経営者になろうと思ったのかについて少しお話しをさせてください
僕は
世の中は理不尽にあふれているそう思っています
いじめやリストらー
急な病気事故など
あげ出せばきりがありません
僕の仲が良かった友人はいじめにあっていました
いじめている加害者に対して
直接ぶつかることができたけど
集団を変えることはできませんでした
僕は彼を
救うことができなかったんです
本当に
無力でした
あの時
僕がもっと強かったのか
今でも思い出すことがあります
また
僕が咆哮3年生の時
当時仲の良かった友人の父親だ会社をクビになってしまいました
彼は5人兄弟の末っ子で
家庭はお世辞にも裕福とは言えない家庭でした
あればいいました
俺
大学に行けないかもしれない
彼は志望校に合格するために明らかに回るよりも努力をしていました
結果だって出てきていました
なのに彼の努力とは裏腹に
お金が理由にあって
自分年代ことをあきらめなければいけない
そんな現実を垣間見ました
この時も
何もできない僕は本当に自分の無力さを痛感しました
だから僕は
自分自身が環境を変えれる人
環境を作れる所になりたいと
そう思うようになりました
そのための手段として作業だと思い僕は弊社になること
決めました
今から2年前
僕は
就職をするか起業するか迷っていました
経営者になることは決めていましたか
就職してから経験を積んで起業するのかそれとも
財学習に学生起業するのか
正直なことを言うと僕は今すぐにでも企業がしたかった
でも
失敗する恐怖や
大企業に就職することすることへの翼に
なかなか覚悟を決めることができませんでした
僕は
複雑に考えな考えすぎてシンプルに考えることができなくなっていました
でも僕は
企業決断します
自分が本当にやりたいことは何なのか考えて決断をしました
僕が死ぬ間際になって
今悩んでいる決断と車を公開するのだろうと
考えました
そうすると
もしここで起業しなかったら一生後悔するんだろうと
なぜか一瞬でわかりました
本当に自分が大切にしたいことを最優先する思考
これこそがシンプルな思考です
シンプルに施工すると自分が本当に望んでいることを見つけやすくなります
逆に言えば
シンプルに施工すると
実際に自分の周りにあるその他の魅力的な選択肢を
各局は2
そして僕は起業家の道を選びました
実際に僕は今まったく後悔していません
むしろ本当に洗濯しちゃったなと思っています
もし僕らー
起業していなかったらこうしてテックス名古屋 u で話すこともなかっただろうなと
思いますね
続いて二つ目の様子です
二つ目の要素はチャレンジです
皆さんチャレンジには必ずついてくることがあります
なんだと思いますか
それは
失敗です
チャレンジと失敗は切っても切り離せない関係にあります
失敗が存在しない
それはチャレンジとは言えませんよねー
失敗することは恐ろしい
そんな思いが皆さんの心の中にもありませんか
僕にもあります
僕は会社を立ち上げて3ヶ月
最初の事業撤退しています
撤退した理由は
このままでは自分たちが目指すビジョンを達成することができないだろうと分かった
からです
1年準備をかけて市場の顕彰会
売り上げが出始めたそんな事業を撤退しました
次の授業で売り上げが出せるのかもわからない
そんな状況で今売り上げが出始めた授業
撤退するというのは
かなり恐怖がありました
そしてなによりも
先導した僕の失敗のせいで0
仲間たちが積み上げたものを台無しにしてしまう
そんな強化
会社を立ち上がってしまっていてお金が出ていく状況で
1から授業を作り直さないといけない
これは花火厳しい決断でした
実際にこの決断に納得できず辞めていくメンバーもいました
それでも僕はこの決断を覆すことはしませんでした
ビジョンが達成できなくても
とりあえずお金が稼げればいいと保守的になることはどうしてもクールだと思えなかっ
たんです
チャレンジには望む結果が得られないことも往々にしてあります
しかしながらチャレンジをしなければ望んだ結果を得られる可能性はゼロです
つまりもし何かを望むならば
一杯を受け入れなければなりません
逆に言えば
大きな成功の裏には必ず数多くの失敗が存在しています
頭ではわかっていても実際に失敗に直面するとかなりダメージがきます
でも失敗をされるのはもったいないです
起業家という職業は特に失敗と親密にすることの多い職業です
僕は
日本のインターネットを変えたその社長や
夜中にスマートフォンをもたらしたスティーブジョブズのようによなともっと良くし
たい
世界を変えたい
そう思っています
きっと僕が世界を入る前にはそれはもう数え切れない事
失敗をするでしょう
でも
それでいい
数多くの失敗の中でたった一回でも夜中があっと驚くような
結果を出してこんなふうに語りたんだと思い
僕が成功できたのは誰よりも失敗をしたからです
こんなふうに書かれたらとてもクールじゃないですか
ウォルトディズニーは言います
夢を見ることができればそれは実現できると
僕はこの言葉がとても好きです
なぜなら
この言葉はとてもシンプルデー
チャレンジすることの良さを表現しているから
僕は
この言葉のように自分の夢を実現するために
これからも自分の理想とするあり方を大切にしていきたいとおもいます
be cool b ハッカー
ありがとうございました
[拍手]